You know,
the idea of dream analysis I suppose is
one of Freud's perhaps Freud's major
contribution to modern western thought.
The idea was there was something to
dreams and I suppose what I did is said,
hey,
look,
isn't it strange we have this whole
other form of thought that we engage in
at night it and it speaks in the
language that we don't really understand
and so what the hell is that?
And you can say,
and many modern people do dreams are of
no significance or even that they're
random processes,
which is an absurd proposition obviously
because they're by Terrell,
whatever they are,
they're obviously not random.
So.
So Freud's idea was that there was some
something in dreams that was
informative,
so that's his.
Now he had a method for describe for
extracting out from the dream what the
dream purported to represent and he
outlined that in great detail in the
interpretation of dreams,
and if you want to read one book by
Freud,
I would highly recommend that one.
It's a very long book and it's very
detailed,
but Freud does it extraordinarily
comprehensive analysis of the way that
dreams work.
Now he made the because because he had
brought a theoretical framework to bear,
even on his investigation into dream
structure,
he concluded that dreams were
essentially wish fulfillments,
and that's where young and Freud
disagreed.
He also believed that the primary
motivating factor of human beings with
sexual,
and now that's a tougher one to toss
aside because even if you're a Darwinian
rather than afraid,
you're going to obviously support the
proposition that sexual motivation among
any living creature is going to be one
of the highest order motivations because
otherwise creatures don't reproduce and
and prevail over the long run.
So the question is,
is that is that the ultimate source of
motivation?
And in some sense the answer to that has
to be yes.
Well,
Freud wanted to make that in some ways
the sole source of motivation,
and I'm over simplifying and I hate to
do that in relationship to Freud because
he was not as simple minded character
young how to dream wants,
if I remember correctly,
that Freud and you were excavating a
basement.
And so freud had outlined in Freud had
already discovered the basement,
let's say.
So that would be the unconscious
structure of the psyche and young broke
through into another basement that was a
multi chambered place.
So many,
many,
many rooms and I suppose what drove
young and freud apart was young's
proposition that there was a hell of a
lot more going down,
going on down there.
Then had already met the eye and they
broke on the idea that the sexual
impulse was primary,
roughly speaking,
they broke when you wrote a book called
symbols of transformation,
which is actually.
There's,
there's three books that I know of that
are sort of like maps of meaning.
One is symbols of transformation.
One is a book by Eric Norman called the
origins and history of consciousness.
And the third and the third
one,
while his maps of meaning,
they're the same book.
They're just like,
they're trying to solve the same problem
from three different directions.
They're all attempts to address the same
problem.
And so symbols of transformation was a
book that you wrote about the fantasies
of schizophrenia,
American woman,
and he was.
He was trying to relate her fantasies to
these old mythological ideas and young's
idea essentially.
And this is an idea that was shared by
people like piaget,
so we were not going to say that you and
or Freud just pulled this idea out of
the air.
Was that the,
the birthplace of myth,
mythology and literature for that matter
was the dream that,
that they share structural that they
share,
they sh,
they share what mode of information
presentation and it's a relatively
radical hypothesis,
but,
but given that they both,
they both represent
hmm
dreams,
dreams and mythological representations
share and essentially narrative
structure and they use their literary
like,
you know,
I mean it's not so unreasonable to
notice that a dream at night is like the
movie that you play in your head and
it's not unreasonable to note as well
that the dreams that you have at night
bear a relationship to the daydreams
that you have during the day.
It's a form of cognition.
It seems like an involuntary form of
cognition though.
And that's a very strange thing.
So young thought about the dream as
nature,
speaking of its own accord,
roughly speaking.
And so his idea was,
well,
when you,
when you sleep you dream.
But the dream happens to you,
it's not something that you create the
way that you don't even think about
creating it,
because I might say,
well,
what are you thinking about?
And you'll say,
I'm thinking about whatever it is and
you'll take credit in some sense for
thinking that because it seems like a
voluntary activity,
but what happens at night is that you
think,
but you think in voluntarily,
and so what young would say is that
means that something is thinking in you
and that's a perfectly reasonable way of
looking at it and this is one of the
things that's uncanny about the cycle
analysts as they they were willing to
take their observations to their logical
conclusion.
There are things that think in you.
What are those things and what are they
thinking and why are they thinking it?
Now,
if you do dream analysis,
and this is a tricky thing because who's
to say if your damn analysis is correct?
Right?
It's very difficult to understand that.
If you.
If you do dream analysis with someone,
you generally have them lay out their
dream and then you ask them when they're
going through their dream of second
time,
they lay out their dream and you can
kind of get a picture of it,
and then they lay out their dream a
second time and as they go through it,
every time they mentioned a detail or a
character,
you ask them what that reminds them of
and the is that the dream is presenting
an image or an idea that's associated
with a network of ideas.
And then if you can expand on the
network of ideas as you go through the
dream,
you can elaborate on the dream.
You can expand it upwards and you can
start to see what it might be attempting
to put forward.
Now,
Freud's idea was that the dream knew
what it was doing,
but that its content was being
suppressed and oppressed by an internal
sensor.
So the dream had to be sneaky about what
it was saying because it was going to
deliver a message that the person didn't
want to hear.
That that was tied up with his idea of
repression,
but that's not young's idea.
See,
young's idea was different.
He said,
no,
no.
The dream is trying to tell you what is
trying to tell you as clear as it can.
That's just the best it can do,
and so you could think of the dream,
and this is I believe,
the right way to think about it.
The dream is the birthplace of thought.
The same way that artists are the
birthplace of culture.
It's exactly the same process.
It's that your mind is groping outward
to try to comprehend what it has not yet
comprehended and it does that first by
trying to map it onto image and it's
doing that in the dream and it's
somewhat incoherent and and,
and well,
let's stick within coherent because it's
not yet a full fledged thought.
It's the birthplace of thought.
It's a fantasy about what might be,
and then if you can grip the fantasy and
share it with other people,
then maybe they can elaborate upon it
and bring it into being with more
clarity than it would be if it merely
existed as the precursor of a thought in
your imagination.